the murder of a central California
police officer is where we begin today
it is escalating the immigration debate
investigators say the suspect was in
this country illegally they believe he's
still in the area
they are asking local residents to help
find him and here's how the shooting
allegedly happened police corporal row
Neil's Singh was shot and killed during
a traffic stop
just hours after Christmas President
Trump mentioned the killing on Twitter
yesterday writing time to get tough on
border security build the wall Mireya
Villarreal is at police headquarters in
Newman California Maria good morning
well good morning the sheriff tells us
they have teams of law enforcement
agencies right now tracking down every
possible lead to find this suspect
officer O'Neill was one of 13 police
officers here at newman and the first
ever to be killed in the line of duty my
department is hurting we're struggling
through this we're a family Newman
California Police Chief Randy Richardson
made a tearful plea for the public's
help in finding the man they say is
responsible for the murder of corporal
row Neel Singh the officer had pulled
over a gray Dodge truck for suspected
DUI early Wednesday morning there was it
was a gunfight
corporal Singh absolutely tried to
defend himself and stop this credible
threat Singh was hit several times and
later died at the hospital
County Sheriff Adam Christianson says
they're now looking for this unnamed
suspect seen here in surveillance and
social media photos
deputies served a search warrant in this
nearby mobile home park and towed away
the suspects truck we are actively
pursuing every investigative lead we
have spared no expense Christensen says
the suspect was in the country illegally
seven months ago the sheriff met with
President Trump and other law
enforcement officials to express his
support for cracking down on illegal
immigrants who break the law there
should be no interference in our ability
to
protect our communities but for now the
Newman community is focused on honoring
Singh's legacy the k-9 officer leaves
behind a wife and young son his
five-month-old he will never hear talk
he doesn't get to hold that little boy
hug his wife because a coward took his
life the county has set up a memorial
fund in honor of corporal Singh and
tonight the community will gather
together here in downtown Newman for a
vigil again in his honor as well Adriana
Miriah thank you